[MUSIC PLAYING]
BOSCO ZUBIAGA: Hi.
My name is Bosco Zubiaga.
I'm a product marketing manager
for Big Data on the Google
Cloud Platform team.
Thank you for joining
our webinar Google
BigQuery, Google's fully managed
data warehouse for large scale
analytics.
I would like to start by giving
you a quick overview of what
we'll cover today.
First, I will go through a
quick introduction on the Google
Cloud Platform.
Then, I've invited
Chad Jennings and Dan
Mcclary, product managers
on BigQuery to join me.
Chad will talk about the
benefits of using BigQuery
and will show you
an exciting demo.
Dan will cover the
origins of BigQuery.
He will then give you
a peek under the hood
so you have a better
understanding of why
BigQuery has such a
great price performance.
Then, he will share with you
some of the latest features
we've added to BigQuery.
He will also
explain how BigQuery
integrates with the larger
Google Cloud Platform.
And then, we'll pass it back to
Chad to talk about our partner
ecosystem.
Let's get started.
With Google Cloud
Platform, we're
building a different
kind of cloud.
The [INAUDIBLE] Google
Cloud of today shares a lot
of similarities
with private data
centers and call
facilities of decades past.
Teams spend a lot of time
thinking about servers, memory,
network connections,
and storage.
And while they're not actually
touching physical gear,
they still have to
manage, monitor,
and care for virtualized
versions of that same gear.
We used to use this kind
of cloud inside Google,
but we realized our
business couldn't
scale fast enough
unless we reduced
the complexity of that model.
We had to reinvent everything
about how we built, deployed,
and run software
on our Cloud to be
able to manage that complexity
out of the equation.
Today, we use 3rd Wave Cloud,
a combination of automated
services and scalable data.
And this is what we offer
through Google Cloud Platform.
Our customers don't
spin up servers,
but their apps serve millions
of users each minute.
They don't shard databases,
write failover scripts,
or patch software stacks.
And yet, their software
is some of the most
resilient and
secure ever created.
This approach lets
our customers code
without thinking
about infrastructure.
Consequently, they do a lot
less unproductive infrastructure
work.
It's an actual global, elastic,
on-demand set of services.
And this is how it
translates to big data.
In a typical big
data world, you have
a lot of these
different things to do.
The valuable part
is programming,
but you also have to provision
resources, manage reliability,
you have to do upgrades.
At Google, we take care
of all of that for you.
You just do the programming,
and the rest of the time
is spent understanding your
data and finding insights.
Now, I would like to
turn it over to Chad
so he can further
explain what BigQuery is
and how it brings the
core values I just
explained to data warehouses.
CHAD JENNINGS: Hi.
My name is Chad
Jennings, and I'm
one of the product managers
for Google BigQuery.
What is BigQuery?
BigQuery is a fully managed,
serverless, enterprise data
warehouse.
What does that mean for you?
It means no touching servers,
no building indices, no managing
upgrades or managing
geo-replications.
When we first built BigQuery
for Google's internal use,
we underestimated how important
these things really were.
But after running inside the
company for more than a decade,
our users really appreciated
this serverless architecture.
BigQuery operates at
petabyte scale and fast.
And we'll show you these
demos in just a second.
We also offer the
convenience of standard SQL,
so you can port over
your existing workloads.
Or, I guess and
another benefit, you
don't have to teach your
analysts a new lingo.
And lastly, we're durable
and highly available.
But what do we actually mean
about high availability?
When you buy a data
warehouse solution,
you generally just
buy the green boxes.
These are the actual
servers that you rent.
You still need to worry about
scaling them, or provisioning
for peak loads, et cetera.
When you buy the
solution from Google,
we take care of this entire
block diagram for you.
Our idea of highly available
analytics is load your data,
and then press the
big red button.
One of BigQuery's
big differentiators
is its query performance over
extremely large data sets.
And so, to convey
this, I'm going
to be showing some queries
over a petabyte of data.
And it's easy to lose track of
how big that number really is.
It's a 1 with 15 zeros.
Or in binary, it's
2 to the 50th.
But what does that really mean?
Well, if you took a
petabyte worth of data
and put it on a stack of 3
and 1/2 inch floppy disks,
you'd have a stack
three miles high.
That's 12 times higher than
the Empire State Building.
If you thought your 4G
connection was pretty quick,
if you tried to download
a petabyte worth of data,
it'd take 27 years.
I really hope those movies
are timeless classics.
The Library of Congress has
every English language book
ever written, as well as
significant audio and video
collections.
Even that only adds up to
10 terabytes' worth of data.
You'd need 100 copies of
the Library of Congress
to add up to a petabyte.
And I don't know exactly
what this says about us
as a society, but
the Twitter corpus
is twice as big as the
Library of Congress.
So you'd need-- to get
to a petabyte-- you'd
need 50 times every
tweet ever tweeted.
Conversely, a
petabyte can actually
be pretty small, as well.
Two micrograms of DNA is
a petabyte worth of data.
And every day--
this is amazing--
a petabyte worth of
videos is uploaded
to YouTube every single day.
And if you had a pretty
significant, but not enormous,
server farm--
200 servers logging
50 entries a second--
you'd have a petabyte worth
of data in three years.
A petabyte, while being a
pretty vast amount of data,
it's the size of data that folks
are using every single day.
And so to show
you how quickly we
can scan through a
petabyte worth of data,
we'll cut to a demo right here.
For this demo, we looked for
a petabyte or bigger data set,
but we couldn't find one.
We couldn't even
find one to buy.
So we built our own.
We used 40 virtual machines
for two weeks solid to generate
this data set.
Let's switch over to the demo.
The dataset is a
retail data set.
If we look here,
the Customers table,
it's an 8-terabyte table
with 4.7 million rows.
The Products table is a half a
gigabyte with 2 million rows.
And the fat table is the
Sales Partition table.
And this one is the big
one, at 1.09 petabytes
and more than a trillion rows.
There are some tricks you can
play with columnar data stores.
And I wanted to show you that
we're not doing any of that.
We're not taking advantage
of column compression
by having the same
element multiple times.
In fact, this table
compresses really poorly
because it's got so many
unique floating point values.
And we don't have large
padding fields, i.e.,
a section of the table that
we're not actually scanning.
I'll just run through and
show you the preview here.
You can see that it's actually
populated with unique numbers
and a lot of them
are floating points.
The first query that
we're going to run
is a select star over the
entire table with a filter
on the Sales Order key.
And so, what this will do is
it'll pick out all the columns,
obviously.
And that's not normal
processing for BigQuery.
Generally, you just pick
the columns that you want.
But we wanted to hammer the
database with a big, fat query.
Let me get this
thing started here.
OK.
And we'll move on
to another example
that's a little bit
more interesting
while that first query runs.
The second query here
computes the total sales
by day for a
particular customer.
And note that we do
filter by customer,
because that means we can't just
use pre-computed aggregations.
I'll go ahead and get
this one running now, too.
All right.
So now we're back with the
results from these queries.
The first query took about
four minutes to process 1.09
petabytes on a pay-as-you-go
instance that took no time
to set up.
That's actually
pretty impressive.
The second of
these large queries
took about five and a
half minutes to finish.
And that's a little bit
longer than the first.
Because, obviously, we're
not just doing select star.
We've got the Filter By Customer
key here, as well as doing
some aggregations, as this query
computes the total sales by day
for a particular customer.
But even so, five
and a half minutes
and four minutes to
scan and do aggregations
over a full petabyte
table is pretty quick.
The previous queries
are quite large.
But we can use partitioning
to save both time and money.
Let's run essentially
the same query
but over a period of time.
Let's say we just want
to find customer sales
in a month's worth of data.
We set up a partition here
to select January of 2005.
And I'll go ahead
and run the query.
And so, while that's going,
what if we wanted, then,
to see how fast we could
do-- oop, there we are.
It finished.
Less than 10 seconds.
Now, let's see.
If we wanted to see actually
how far we can push this.
So how fast can we
do a partition scan
on this petabyte sales data?
I'll just select
January 4th of 2005.
And let's see how that one goes.
All right.
There we go, finished in
less than five seconds.
That's five seconds to query
an entire petabyte table.
That's pretty darn quick.
The other queries that
we ran with partitions
were a bit small and used simple
scan filter aggregate queries.
Let me get this one running.
It's a bit more ambitious.
And then, we'll
explain what it does.
This query computes the
seven-day average sales
across a range of
products defined
by a regular expression.
We're also going to join
against the products table
in order to look up
the product name.
There we are.
It's finished.
Less than 20 seconds.
In the first two queries, we
scanned the full petabyte table
and got results back in
just a couple of minutes.
Then using partitions,
we drastically
reduced the time and
cost of the queries
to pull data for
specific time periods.
The last query is a
relatively complex one
using regular expressions,
partitions, a join,
and aggregations to return
the seven-day average sales
of a range of products taken
from that petabyte table
all in less than 20 seconds.
That's pretty darn fast.
We'll head back to the talk.
BOSCO ZUBIAGA: Now
that was a cool demo.
After seeing that,
I'm sure you are
wondering what makes
BigQuery so fast
and how BigQuery was developed.
And now, I'm going
to turn it over
to Dan so he can explain
where BigQuery came from,
how it works, and the influence
it has had on the big data
industry.
DAN MCCLARY: Hi.
I'm Dan McClary, part
of the BigQuery team.
Now, we've heard a lot about
how BigQuery can really
change organizations for
the better with its ability
to analyze petabytes of data.
We've also heard a lot about
what BigQuery practically is.
But after hearing
all of this, it's
worth reflecting for a moment.
How did we get here?
Where did BigQuery come from?
And that's what we're
going to look at right now.
Now, it's important, when we
think about where BigQuery came
from, to think about Google's
long history of tackling
big data problems.
At Google, we like
to publish papers.
And we like to tell the world
what we've been building.
Because we think it
helps other organizations
build things that are
truly revolutionary.
This goes all the way
back to our earliest days.
In 2002 and 2004, we published
a pair of papers about systems
called GFS and MapReduce.
These papers actually gave the
initial idea to Doug Cutting
for the Apache Hadoop project,
which has taken the big data
world by storm.
More recently, we've
published papers
on Dataflow and
TensorFlow, systems
which have generated
a lot of excitement
around streaming
data and analytics,
and machine learning.
One of the papers that we
published was called Dremel.
And this was about
a system that we
built inside Google
that's been really
important to the development
of the big data ecosystem.
What was the Dremel paper?
Well, the Dremel paper
was based on a system
that was written by an engineer
here called Andrey Gubarev.
Now, Andrey had a problem.
He was trying to
write MapReduces
over many, many, many logs.
And it took a long time.
This is a problem analogous
to what many people
using open source big data
problems have dealt with.
Now, what Andrey did
is he started storing
his logs in a columnar format.
And then, he wrote a little
SQL query engine over it.
And it was way faster.
And that was really interesting.
And soon he'd attracted
the attention of an intern
and some other engineers.
And there was a snowball effect.
And Dremel became a big deal.
And this paper was a bit of
a hallmark for the big data
space, as well.
Because this paper gave rise to
both the Apache Parquet Storage
project and to SQL and Hadoop
solutions like Cloudera's
Impala and Apache Drill.
Now, where is Dremel today?
Well, Dremel today is
still used inside Google.
Dremel is Google's mission
critical data warehouse.
It's been in production
for 10 years.
It's in every
Google data center.
And for internal usage, we
query on the order exabytes
of data a month.
That's an order of magnitude
bigger than the petabyte
we were talking about earlier.
And what does that stack up to?
That sets up to quadrillions
of rows scanned every month.
And 80% of Googlers
use it every day.
Some of them don't even know it.
And Dremel is BigQuery.
When you use Google Cloud
BigQuery, you're using Dremel.
It's the same system.
We launched it to the
public as a beta in 2010
and made it generally
available in 2012.
It's the same engineering
team and the same codebase.
It's exactly the same
system brought to you.
In the past five years, we've
been busy improving Dremel.
We just didn't write
it and let it sit idle.
You take a look
at the graph here,
the yellow line
shows you the number
of code changes to Dremel
over the last five years.
And these are the same code
changes that go into BigQuery.
Each of the blue flags
represents a major milestone
that we think is
important to customers.
These are things like Dremel
X, which we'll talk about
in a moment, and some
of the other things
that we've done around faster
data ingestion and better
support for the SQL language.
Well, that's five
years of innovation.
But what have we done lately?
Well, to take a look
at this, we first
have to take a look at
BigQuery's architecture.
Now, importantly,
BigQuery disaggregates
Storage and Compute.
This allows us some
real advantages.
We can summon thousands
of virtual CPUs
in an instant to
service a query.
However, this is all dependent
on Google's incredibly fast
data center networking.
Because our networks
have a petabit bisection,
it means that even
though that Storage is
separate from Compute,
it runs as if it was all
on the same gigantic
machine, so that petabyte
can be scanned and processed
incredibly quickly.
One of the improvements
we made was to the way
that Dremel actually
allocates these virtual CPUs
to the task at hand.
Let's take a look at the Dremel
architecture from 2006 to 2015.
In this case, we relied on what
we called a Long-lived Serving
Tree.
This looks very similar--
to those of you coming from
the database world--
to a directed, acyclic
processing graph,
or a query plan.
And that's exactly what it is.
This was very useful,
in terms of be
able to optimally scan
and process lots of data
for common queries.
However, for certain kinds of
queries, it maybe wasn't ideal.
Recently, we produced
something called Dremel X.
And this architecture
is much more dynamic.
You can think about this
as Dremel's optimizer,
or BigQuery's optimizer,
getting much smarter
about how to allocate
compute units in an instant
to the queries at hand.
What does this mean for you?
This means massive
joins get faster.
Most queries got an order
of magnitude faster,
and everything just works.
And Dremel X is available
as part of BigQuery now.
Users who switch to the system
didn't even know they switched.
They just woke up and
queries got much faster.
And we continue to
make improvements
like this to BigQuery everyday.
We've talked a
little bit about how
BigQuery takes advantage
of a legacy of big data
advances inside Google.
But where does it fit within
Google Cloud platform's data
architecture or your
own data architecture?
Let's take a look.
If we zoom in, one of the things
we might really care about
is the fundamentals of data
warehousing or big data
systems.
Where do I load and store data?
And then, how am I going
to analyze and understand
that data?
If we look at the Load and
Store side of the house,
you can see three
things that really
form the heart of that part
of our reference architecture.
You have Google
Cloud Dataflow, which
is used for ETL,
streaming aggregation,
and a number of other things.
You have Google
Cloud Storage, which
is designed for incredibly
low-cost, planet-scale storage.
And then, we have systems
like Google BigTable, which
is designed for iOT data, time
series, and other things that
tend to be column
family in nature.
On the analysis side,
we've got BigQuery,
which, obviously, we've been
talking quite a lot about.
But for those of you who
want to take advantage
of the open source big data
space like Hadoop and Spark,
we have Google Cloud Dataproc.
And this allows you
to run the latest
versions of Hadoop and Spark
in a fully managed cluster
in seconds.
I have an arrow between
these two things.
It says full integration.
What does that mean?
Well, full integration
means that I
don't have to draw little arrows
between each of these hexagons
to tell you, this
thing connects to that,
this other thing
connects this way,
you can only do this
with this other thing.
Full integration means all of
these products in Google Cloud
Platform are designed to
work together, seamlessly,
without any extra
effort on your part.
But what about other things?
There are other things that we
do with data other than load
and store it, and analyze
and understand it.
So let's take a bit
of a broader look.
We want you to be able to
ingest data into Google Cloud
Platform from anywhere.
And we do this, in part,
through technologies
like our own Google
Cloud Pub/Sub, which
allows you to do
scalable message queuing
from anywhere in the world, but
also through tools that you may
use today, like ETL
tools such as Talend,
or data wrangling
tools like Trifacta.
And on the other side, we
know that it's important
that you be able to visualize
data the way you want to,
explore it easily, and
share it with others, which
is why both BigQuery and
Google Cloud Dataproc are fully
integrated with solutions like
Tableau and MicroStrategy,
as well as with
our own solutions,
such as Google Analytics 360
and its Data Studio 360 project,
and with things like Google
Cloud Datalab, which provides
data scientists a
flexible environment
to both write their
own code and integrate
with systems like BigQuery.
We talked earlier in this
webcast about the fact
that BigQuery is fully managed.
And what is fully managed mean?
Well, we think fully
managed means getting more.
It means that as
a BigQuery user,
you get solutions like
Dynamic Execution immediately.
You wake up one day and
BigQuery just get a lot faster.
Your queries got
easier to write.
It also means things like
Project Poseidon come to you.
And you wake up, and
things get better.
Poseidon allows you to all of a
sudden load new kinds of files,
such as AVRO file formats.
It also means that most
ingestions got 10 times faster.
And you get this
all, just one day,
without having to do anything.
And then, things like consistent
scheduling, as we mentioned,
BigQuery's
architecture allows us
to summon a vast number
of CPUs instantaneously
to service your query.
But at the same time, we
make sure you're always
going to have more
than enough resources
to handle your queries.
And so, fully managed means
you get the latest innovations
without having to go
through painful upgrades,
whether it's on the query
execution side, or the data
storage side.
And it also means you
always have the resources
you need to process your data.
Now, I'm going to
throw it back to Chad,
who's going to talk a little
bit more about other partners
and how they integrate
with Google BigQuery.
CHAD JENNINGS:
BigQuery isn't trying
to be everything to everyone.
In places where we're not
building functionality,
we need to partner with
outstanding companies
to provide that functionality
to our customers.
You can see here four
different functional areas
from visualization
to data preparation.
It's important for BigQuery to
use these other technologies
so that you, as a company,
if you use MicroStrategy,
or if you use Talend or Tableau,
you can still use those tools,
but have BigQuery
as your backend.
Thanks for taking the
time to watch the webinar.
On behalf of my other
speakers, I just
wanted to extend that thank you.
And if you're curious
about learning more,
you can go to
cloud.google.com/bigquery.
Take care.
[MUSIC PLAYING]